yeah
morning Millennials welcome to the
morning toast which is today being
rebranded as the morning [ __ ] Bo
because Jackie and I are both
coincidentally wearing a [ __ ] bow shirt
or just such a coincidence we we have
the common denominators that we have a
big time magazine editor meeting later
and we were talking about it last night
not Claudia was saying she was gonna
wear her [ __ ] bow outfit and I'm the
one that I never got to wore on the
private jet that I just took off because
I didn't make it to Austin and I was
actually planning on wearing a [ __ ] bow
so we knew we were both wearing [ __ ]
bows but we came to it wasn't
coordinated well technically it wasn't
because I didn't do it intentionally
it wasn't coordinated I wasn't shocked
today so it wasn't a surprise but it
wasn't coordinated okay I stand by I'm
correct it wasn't coordinated no but it
won't okay
but it wasn't shocked okay but
coordinated a job or two legs Wednesday
was according to Sigma she showed up say
what acquaintance
it wasn't coordinated a little bit
coordinated today's a crazy day because
I walk in and they're like Sansa Stark
is here and everyone was like oh my god
Santa's in the building and I'm like no
no let me in I know her and I was
expecting there to be like some big
security guard but Lincoln and then oh
they just let me walk right into her
makeup room and she was looking so
gorgeous and I was like oh my god you're
just blowing up on the Madison Square
Garden thing did you see that and I was
like you're everyone like oh she's like
oh you were there I was like no I just
saw Instagram like everyone else she
called me outta my [ __ ] that's but
she's like where's the studio I want to
come by and so if Sansa Stark just walks
in today just like don't be alarmed just
try not to drop dead like but I did tell
her that we were in the wrong studio so
I told her we were in like studio L or
whatever and that's the one she's in
obviously wonderful I don't know if I
can handle Sciences today it's a big day
back I can't believe I've been mi a yes
tell us about serving my similar god
Sarah it was seeing such a nerd like she
was texting us about like the case and
the judge and like she wouldn't give us
any details she's like no I'm not
allowed you're not allowed apparently
and so there's only so much I mean
obviously I didn't make the cut mostly
because uh the case it was a big case it
was it was one it was a big one and it
would have required a lot of time and my
job just doesn't allow for that really
the toasters don't allow for that and
there were so many like other jurors
there who were either unemployed or in
between jobs or out-of-work actors
waiting for the next Broadway show
waiting for the next big break so if
they were actually looking to be on the
jury
so you know a morning show host it's not
there's a lot of people that depend on
me every day and the case was already
known it was gonna be a long time so I
had to bow out for that reason I was out
but I had a wonderful time and I just
jeurys but he's really not as bad as
people the hardest part about it is like
waking up and getting downtown by 9:00
a.m. well it depends because it's
actually quite interesting or your
pussy's becoming unbowed mmm it's only
interesting like if they choose you and
you go through the round I went for two
days and sat in the same room and never
got chosen like that's [ __ ] boring
yeah that's boring but you got a lot of
work done like I created in the my words
oh sorry
is it now tied in the bow no no no it's
okay it's good we're good in the morning
before I got chosen for something I was
working on the behind the scenes video
by the time I got home I was ready to
upload no I just remember being like in
college being so hungry and bored and
just like watching entourage and this
uncomfortable chair like okay if I was
like in a leather recliner I would have
been a little bit more comfortable but
know this like government-issued plastic
folding chair just wasn't working for me
I don't know it was it was a lot the
chairs were decent have a sensitive
tailbone and the people who were running
jury duty like you expect them to be
government worker is DMV like [ __ ]
but they like got on the mic which they
do every single day and I seems to have
a rehearse script and honestly it's a
comedy show a little bit they were
making so many jokes it was hilarious
though I had watch a little of different
attacking about the vending machine and
like they're saying so matter-of-factly
they were like if your snack get stuck
you are allowed to shake the machine but
we will not reach out to you that is so
fun it was so funny and I was just it
wasn't as treacherous I've been putting
it off like for so long and it just
wasn't so terrible and I got out
yesterday pretty early I can't discuss
the details of the case but now I'm
invested I'm gonna google it and like
try and keep up I convinced Margo that I
was going to be a juror on the college
admissions scam okay and she really
believed it's like [ __ ] that happen in
California they have any Massachusetts
whatever she was like no way I was like
yeah yeah there is no way okay so you
can't disclose any of it but do you
think the guy did it but no because he's
innocent until proven guilty
and you would actually be a fantastic
juror that's what's so crazy it's like
yes you have a job and something like I
could have held down the fort like sort
of because you really would have you
were so unbiased like if that was me
back now he totally did it
Durocher you are truly the rural juror
and the judge was really just so
compelling he was
such a great guy first of all we all the
potential jurors walk into the room and
we run out of benches you know what are
those called pews for people to send of
course in the first person to not get a
seat so I'm standing against the wall so
that's so funny because that's the
difference between you and I like I
would [ __ ] beeline for a chair like
elbow I didn't know it was gonna be an
issue
we were just filing in single file I go
to then there's no more seats they're
like line up against the wall I'm like
me and my heavy backpack it was so yeah
because I wanted to bring all gadgets
and gizmos a-plenty for myself busy and
like a backpack is a functional item so
I'm standing against the wall like of
course this would happen to me I can
barely sit let alone stand and the judge
comes in and he goes before we begin to
any of the young men want to give up
their seats for the women and the
elderly chivalry and I was like wow wow
wow judge just just wow I would did you
get a chair I did front row center and I
was so grateful and I feel like that
doesn't happen anymore
and I know that it's going the way of
the horse and buggy because we don't see
gender but in that moment I very much
saw gender and I was grateful that the
judge did as well no because you know
it's so funny it's like for a guy they
don't even realize like oh it's a chair
but for a woman like to stand with her
big tits for an hour like it's literally
debilitating like and they don't even
think anything of it so it's not that
they're intentionally being read that
rude they don't they just don't realize
it like a woman having to stand for an
hour like for me specifically like a big
breasted chubby Jewish woman having to
stand for an hour I can literally take
years off my life you know totally they
hadn't eaten and anyone wasn't gonna eat
and I was just like that's ugh yeah
so the judge sounds like a really good
guy he was a really good guy and he made
like some he understood the treachery of
jury duty and there were a lot of times
walk during the selection process he
would ask a question and if you had a
conflict or something you were excused
and he was saying this will be a long
trial and I understand that you're for
your job it might not be feasible but
just know like this is your civic duty
any one of us in this room myself
included could wind up in a position
where we need a jury and like would you
you know try and make it work who's
guilty you into it he was real and you
know he really he spoke to me I was I
guess technically it's not ideal for me
to be on a long trial but gun to my head
I could do it right and I realized there
is no gun to my head
the anxiety and stress that it would
cause would actually hinder my ability
to be a rural juror and I was excused I
feel like I'm already talking about it
you might even talk about the keys and
just talking about jury duty and they
were very there to say like don't talk
about on social media and I was like
well you know if selected like that
would be really hard for me right that's
what that would be my excuse not only am
i you know on tour I can't actually you
know just partake in these like little
activities I also would have a very hard
time not keeping my mouth shut
on social media so I didn't I think you
should let me go you can't even selfie
like just in the courthouse being like
hey like at jury duty
well they can't post anything good stuff
so I mean I hope no one's seeing this
but I don't think I talked about the
case you know I also just don't think we
have a lot of judges watching our show
you know yeah and except for Miss Aqua
Lena I just want to say I by the end of
it I was very ready to serve my country
um and jury duty is just not as terrible
as they as it's made out to me maybe
it's gotten better maybe they've
realized that like everyone's blowing
this thing off um so I got a lot of work
done productive enjoyable got you know
to meet this great judge you make any
friends I kind of did and then a toaster
messaged me they're like my friend was
on the jury with you and I'm like okay
well no toasters came up to me it felt
like a very anti toaster zone oh my god
toilet not touch the front was like now
I know in hindsight there are people
that knew who I was and I was like and
you know what that also drives you
unqualified right like you can't I was
telling this on another episode with
Taylor Stryker but you know my friend
Jenna she in high school was on charge
UT with Donald Trump Wow
but before he was even political like he
was in New York resident like a
well-known one and he was like you know
just chillin with everyone but like he's
also not like if you're notable I don't
think you'd like does Tom Hanks serve on
a jury you know he gets called for jury
duty and I feel like it's one of those
things like you know how celebrities
have like people who go to the DMV for
them like they get through in through a
back door in the DMV and in colleges um
I wonder if jury duty is one of those
things it's like how can just
celebrities because even it's like the
low-level public figure that I am very
very very low I was thinking like I'm a
public figure ish and it's a weird thing
I think they still have to go but they
get automatically excused like it would
really it would not be fair for a
million reasons to have like a huge
celebrity on the jury yeah I feel like
today I'm wearing a white shirt like I'm
always wearing black you can act
see the length of my hair well so you
got a haircut I see the first time I'm
seeing it in person I meant to get a
trim but like I unintentionally like did
something dramatic but you know what I'm
really liking it just a lot lighter and
like just looks super healthy literally
weight off my shoulders even Theo both
and Olivia and Olivia right it's just
like this it's the haircut week you know
I'm just wring his sprung today so here
same spring you got is yes and it's
Rebecca's birthday and we always have a
debate because I was raised to think
that the season start on the 21st June
but she says it's the 20th and because
her birthday is March 20th she's in the
start of spring and she's so [ __ ]
spring it's annoying what are the cows
like when the weather is good it's like
let's go get drinks Oh actually drinks
yeah I think we're let's go sit in the
park or some [ __ ] that drinks in the
park yeah yeah let's have class outside
today drinks outside yeah oh she was
always voting for class outside and so
she like so weird oh so good
20th is spring I always said was a 21st
but because it's her birthday she's an
expert on like great day actually means
but what is that what are your planner
says and the planner has always forced a
spring to display with you yeah it's in
there we'll check it later we'll check
later um yes so I'm just making a lot of
changes in my life like for spring like
just a new woman like I clean my
apartment I got a haircut I signed up
for guitar lessons and I bought a guitar
Jackie you're gonna die it's the cutest
guitar ever that's so crazy because I am
buying a piano you are I'm gonna sign up
for piano
I'm gonna start should we start a band I
think so I think that's what they chose
me is in like maybe we could like go on
the road like dr. Shirley oh but I'm
Amazon I bought it I would be my uh
what's that guy's name your driver Tony
the lip
I could be your driver yeah so let me
get it you're the talent I don't know
head and I'm the higher though piano
player yeah I love bumpy and I don't
know how to drive so naturally you would
drive in less like we would want a third
person in the car but that takes up
seeds look at this guitar you would
protect me that is like so insulting
look at this guitar for a sparkly
cuteness Gorge there's no way that it
like works right no it was very
expensive and I found it on Guitar
Center but then I put her on Amazon
because I just thought it would come
faster on her and I take my research
like we won an acoustic - I want a
classical and I don't want a classical
like I want but I don't want to like
sure Katara so I found out there's a
thing called an acoustic electric that
is like a classical guitar but it also
has an amp on the thing that you could
plug in and TPG when I was at his house
in the Hamptons he had won this thing at
music cares gala benefit in an auction
anyways what guitar signed by Reba and
Kelsea Ballerini and he told me I could
have it but I didn't take it home with
me that day and like now I'm living a
life of regret coz like what am I gonna
get it but like now that I'm taking back
guitar like I need to start a collection
of guitars and I need that guitar in my
life ok well this summer hopefully he'll
invite you out to the Hamptons snag it
well so now this is just like me on my
journey to you know I'm going to LA next
week to record a secret project and I
just think having a guitar in hand and
like my talent would be important and
now if you need a piano player right I
really think this could be great for and
biz me too oh my god I didn't realize
it's so funny ok I was worried about
your teacher
well not that this isn't add or anything
so I told you I'm gonna start taking I'm
doing three cooking classes in April
there's like this website called course
horse that is for classes like real
classes in the city and like you can
find any sort of class so I'll find a
teacher probably through that or maybe
like Craigslist I got a referral cuz if
I'm gonna do it in my house I'm like
weird about letting people into my house
with that so I got a referral from my
friend Lila from high school because she
was like I was playing guitar in her
house I'm like you totally have a guitar
teacher and she did and his name is like
drew and I just texted him wow that's so
exciting
and I was inspired to at a piano because
the Foxwoods and I was like wow my
muscles are very memorable
what else could could be things do we I
had a piano in my dressing room in
Foxwoods which was the first time ever
and probably the last but it felt very
very prestigious yeah we were while you
were gone I mean we're tearing it out
you have an out jamming out like I just
feel like if we both like play the
instrument we could just have like
hardcore like jam session right and then
technically people couldn't say we don't
have talent right right did you read
boxwoods yes because you the best of my
ability if you want to enjoy the
assyrians patron calm slash and wearing
toast we did it behind the scenes of
Foxwoods and it's just so fun it was a
fun one it was really lit and I'd never
been to Foxwoods before and I definitely
will return because like I didn't gamble
enough and any party enough honestly I
didn't gamble at all I just made me
really feel like we need another family
AC weekend like kind of soon yeah we're
degas we are working on we're working on
I guess but Vegas is like a lot of
spring is already nailing up spring is
sprung I mean it has and you know what
else is sprung the Fast Five story is
that you need
before you wake up and take a bite out
of your morning toast Kapow um kapowie
okay first story just closing the loop
on an ongoing wild a story that somehow
we have forgotten because the collective
amnesia of our society is is truly
staggering and sometimes it comes in
handy you know because it's like when
this story first came out it was the
greatest thing ever like no one could
talk about anything else like it was
literally on my mind 24/7 and I'd
literally haven't thought about this
person since then and when I saw the
update I truly didn't give a [ __ ] right
but it's like the update is important
because a big part of this story was who
leaked Jeff Bezos intimate and cringy
texts question mark National Enquirer a
National Enquirer reportedly paid Loren
Sanchez's brother $200,000 for Bezos
text also the headline reads as Lauren
Sanchez's brother sold her sister's text
message and sold his soul to the devil
Enquirer for 22 grand the National
Enquirer deadly didn't reach out to the
brother that hey can we see her sister
sex he definitely took it to the
National Enquirer like these headlines
like they don't put enough blame on his
yeah for this dirty dirty move I always
in so shocked when like family turns on
family just cuz like we're so not like
that I'm like even if you were like the
worst you did the worst thing ever to me
like I would never betray you do you
know any because I'm family right and
honestly if you were to betray me I hope
you would get more than $200,000 for it
no actually judges were worth him at
least a million dollars yeah just
because of the Pro like Jeff Bezos and
like who he is and and like there
weren't nude selfies involved right but
those never came to fruition sadly right
there's just a myth like you know yeah
please
I currently they exist like the world of
Atlantis oh yeah they're another city
buried under scene with just bezos's
nudes mm-hmm and you can only imagine
what they look like honestly and you
know what you don't have to imagine
there it is I know the top of his head
is just like the little cap of his fetus
sneak peek yeah stop it's so wild that
we are talking about Jeff basis is penis
with familiarity considering he is the
richest and like most prestigious
businessman of all time it's also crazy
like how you can joke about a man's like
dick pics being leaked over like a
woman's like when it's a woman it's a
true invasion of privacy in this first
Sheryl Sandberg right or like remember
when Jennifer Lawrence there was like
that
huge like hack and like a bunch of nude
and like it was really like we didn't
even look at it we thought it was such
an invasion of privacy but I'm like if
Jeff Bezos has nudes I'm like give me
them now and I'm gonna send them to
everyone I know
it really is it's so true it's like
[ __ ] up it's [ __ ] up like the way we
kept talking about Colton not we we
never did but the way Chris Harrison
kept talking about Colton's virginity
that were eventually it's outwardly the
Bachelorette we're a virgin and they
were talking that much he would be in
prison he would be fired yeah a hundred
percent the National Enquirer paid the
brother of Jeff Bezos his mistress
$200,000 for the racy text messages and
other dirt used in their story that sunk
the billionaire's marriage a report said
the tabloid paid the money to Michael
Sanchez the brother of Bezos mistress
Lauren Sanchez with a nun fro upfront
contract in exchange for the text
messages used in 11 page spread spread
about their affair that was published in
January according to The Wall Street
Journal Michael Sanchez who has who has
been a longtime source for The Enquirer
is this true ooh informant began
speaking to the tabloid about Bezos and
his sister's relationship last fall
according to the report Sanchez and The
Enquirer fire finalized the deal on
October 26 the Inquirer's lawyer cameron
Straker included an upfront payment in
the contract to prove the story would
quote not be a catch and kill operation
similar to once it had carried out on
behalf of President Trump during the
2016 presidential election the newspaper
how do you get paid for something like
this is it a check is it cash is it a
wire is a direct deposit like because
this technically isn't illegal you're
paying for information I mean it's
stolen and for me so they don't have to
hide it so I mean maybe it was like what
would you prefer
do you accept paypal wait actually it
isn't legal because it's stolen nude
photos of someone that's not legal I
haven't seen illegal in any of unless
and unless this girl Michelle Sanchez
said her name Lauren Sanchez Lauren
Sanchez was such a dumb [ __ ] and sent
to the nude photos to her brother being
like lol look at this then he
technically owns them because someone
gave them to him yeah well that's the
thing here it's like okay you know this
brother
everyone's got like a family member
who's maybe off the rails a little bit
so here we go but hopefully you wouldn't
send so the brother okay
the brother whatever but
Sanchez obviously somehow either left
her phone in the hands of your brother
who's clearly you know the bad seed huh
and so what's the craziest part to me is
that Jeff basis is still with her
considering how has he not asked himself
how did the brother get his hands on
these things no I mean Jeff Bezos has a
lot of things and smart is one of them
so I have to believe that he did a
thorough investigation into her
culpability I think this is definitely
of book smarts her street smarts it's
like he has no street smarts in this
sense right where it's like we have no
book smart well I have no book smart but
I have tons of street smart right I
never let myself sleep with someone who
would sell my soul to the devil
exactly I just I can't believe that
they're still together and that and he's
not questioning how the brother got his
hands on the messages and you know what
it's like where is mrs. Bezos in all of
this poor woman poor woman I mean not
poor woman you know what she's probably
hanging out with another fellow a woman
who got injustice from a rich man mrs.
Herjavec I am like out here trying to
get justice for mrs. Herjavec I feel
like what Robert did was really not cool
okay and I'm on the opposite side where
it's like justice for Robert who it
seemed like the who's not a bad guy no
he's definitely been separated from his
wife when he met please clean gave him a
spring in he got a taste of the Tipsy l
was money and he wanted more he loved
the lifestyle of the rich and famous
being now Dancing with the Stars on a
network show and he didn't want it's
like old wife with him he wanted new
kicks and you know what I watch shark
tank and I laugh and I indulge but I
never forget what Robert Herjavec did to
the og mrs. Herjavec and now Kim hurt
you back it's like out here in Instagram
being at camera heard you back
it's like Britney all team it's like
it's sweet you guys are building a house
but like let me not forget how you two
met
I'm sorry Wow you're gonna be that yeah
it's like when we first heard about
Britney whatever her Oh G name was
you're gonna be was a Melman she was the
woman who took away lovely mrs. Aldine
from Jason okay let me I know it's like
so see like they have a house and
children she must see that forget do you
feel that way about Lala Ken 100% Wow I
feel like whatever they blow it once you
have a house and children you've made it
right you know yes it doesn't feel that
way about Margaret Joseph's
because I don't okay I'm not saying I
feel okay now
I don't feel alright Marga Joseph's
because I love her but all I'm saying is
like lest we not forget I'm not saying
that they make it right yes the pain
goes away now that there's a family and
children and a big house but all I'm
saying is lest we not forget and I'll
leave it at that I don't see it that way
you know timing is everything and you
can't just help when you meet the right
person and under the wrong circumstances
I don't know it all seems a key to me I
feel like once you get married and
especially when you have children and
you've made it right up until that point
it's like a key as hell but but when you
let the children from the first marriage
like they never get justice you know let
your family what that they're not got
divorced their family was broken up at
the hands of Brittany Aldi you know I
guess all I'm saying I don't know I can
say it with me all I'm saying oh I said
say it with me not before me all I'm
saying is ready
forget me that's not oh my god lest we
not forget I mean if Jeff Bezos marries
this woman I would definitely not forget
let's do we not forget honestly put that
on my gravestone okay this is what I
wanted to say at my tombs really I know
it is lived her life
lest we not forget that she lived her
life maintaining a chubby physique yes
and underneath that it says except
you're not maintaining all it's gonna
say underneath that is I know what you
did Brittany aldeen justice for mrs.
Herjavec Wow okay and I'll leave it at
that I like Brittany looking fab today
you know what you're looking just fab
am i yes I'm Jeff have VIP members so is
Jackie it's route truly changed my life
JustFab brings him everything that's new
and trending and shoes clothing and
accessories so you can look like a
million bucks on your budget even if you
don't know where to start just fab makes
the entire shopping process fun and
exciting with their very own style quiz
love style Quigs quiz there are no wrong
answers just great style recommendations
VIP save up to 30% on retail prices and
gain access to tons of other exclusive
perks you can shop as a guest or become
fehb the IP and take it from me becoming
a VIP is by far the best way to shop and
listen up now is the time to sign up as
a VIP because right now you'll get your
first style for 75% off as well as $10
this is an exclusive deal for our
podcast listeners so make sure you go to
justfab.com slash toast to get it that's
just fab dot-com slash toast to get your
first style for as low as $10 you can't
beat that justfab.com slash say it with
me toast
that's exciting continue honestly I get
so hungry you get like nauseous I'm like
sick yes you know I was just drinking my
coffee and I was feeling nauseous and I
was like what would happen if I threw up
on the show I know why I'm feeling
nauseous
because I had like truly like a
one-of-a-kind experience today in an
uber where I just happened to be in like
the smallest car ever I don't know what
it was it was it was a Nissan Altima
like it wasn't that small but like
everything about it was small like I
felt a big the driver was big both the
seats were pushed back and it was so
tiny and so hot and he was wearing so
much Cologne like you know people hotbox
her pot yeah I was hot-boxed with Paco
Rabanne did you open a window of course
I did it asked me if it helped to ask me
no but you have to stick your head out
like feel like a dog truly oh feels like
nacho very well when I was gone for like
a week
Theo stayed in between his grandparents
and his dog walker and they both just
like left him so much that they like
indulge him and feed him too much and
I'm like really strict when it comes to
Theo's diet not my own just Theo's and
it's because his breed is has a
predisposition to congenital heart
failure and their weight has a lot to do
with that so he's been on a very strict
diet for about a week and he got a
haircut so he was looking slim and
trimmed today like getting compliments
from everyone in the building yeah he
needs to get it start working on his
summer body he is but you know he's not
there yet no he's really took his winter
body you know I did a judge totally even
though spring has sprung Julie next
story is really crazy
tearful Wendy Williams reveals she's
living in a sober-living house Wendy
Williams has revealed that she's been
living in a sober house the 54 year old
talk-show host
opened up to her viewers on Tuesday's
episode of the Wendy Williams Show she
told her fans that she wanted to be
truthful and share her story with them
quote so you know me for being a very
truthful and open person and I've got
more to the story for you Williams said
during her show as she held back tears
you know Kevin Kevin and I have
Hunter foundation for the good of the
people I mean recently just you know
it's confusing she said Kevin Kevin and
I I think her husband's name is Kevin
and her son because she kept saying she
does it twice Kevin Kevin and I read
that too and I just thought she's like
no Kevin Kevin and I know Kevin Kevin
and I got it and we recently launched
our eight eight eight five hunter number
for those of you caught up in the
struggle of addiction well for some time
now and even today and beyond I've been
living in a sober house when you see me
come to work glammed up right after the
show I go across the street I do my
Pilates I told you two hours a day or
like to care I like to take care of my
body and you know I've had a struggle
with cocaine in my past I never went to
a place to get the treatment I don't
know how God except God was sitting on
my shoulder and I just stopped but there
are people in your family it might be
you you have been struggling and I want
you to know more of the story so this is
my autobiographical story and I'm living
it I'm telling you this after I go to
the Pilates I go to several meetings all
around town in the tri-state area and
they see my brothers and sisters caught
up in their addiction and looking for
help they don't know I'm Wendy they
don't care I'm Wendy there's no
autographs there's nothing it's the
brothers and sisters caught up in the
struggle it's been really interesting
this ride Williams then shared that only
her husband Kevin and her son Kevin knew
about this not my parents nobody nobody
knew because I look so glamorous out
here after I finished my appointments
see my brothers and sisters breaking
bread I'm driven by me 24 hours sober
coach back to the home that I live in
here in the tri-state air tri-state with
a bunch of smelly boys who have become
my family they had the TV and watch
soccer we talk and read and talk and
read and then I get bored with them
doors locked by 10:00 p.m.
lights out by 10:00 p.m. so I go to my
room and I stare at the ceiling and I
fell asleep to wake up and come back
here to see you so that is my truth I
mean I have so many thoughts on this but
my overall thought is brave [ __ ]
seasoned out here for Wendy Williams and
I I've always just like taken a liking
to my new belly and I don't consistently
watch her show but every time I do I was
like you know what she's not afraid to
say this and I just really liked her
then she took this hiatus and was like a
little shady about it and there was
obviously more to it and it's not our
business but she's always like Brandon
her self is like this honest and woman
of the people relatable and even when
she was getting into that fight with
Howard Stern she was like we both
started as like relatable men and women
of the people and I'm like what you're
lying about something like so obviously
everyone comes out on their own terms I
thought it was so great of her and at
the end of the day like she didn't even
have to tell anyone like she could have
gotten away with not telling anyone this
but she told and I was just like I was
so shocked I was not expecting her to be
this upfront and honest and I was like
loving it I love it too I think she's
gonna help so many people because you
probably stigmatize like living in a
sober house if you don't associate that
with being on TV every day being glammed
up and so she's saying you know not
everything is what it seems people are
struggling I'm struggling anything she's
gonna help a lot of people and also I
feel like maybe she's ever intended to
tell people but because everyone is
still harping on like what was going on
she felt the need to speak about it and
also if someone at another celebrity was
doing this and she was talking and that
man in their show should I call it out
so I feel like she's practicing what
she's pinching she's walking the walk
she's talking the talk that's so true so
much so much respect I have so much
respect for her and anyone who's trying
to do the right thing and like get right
and get their life on track
I couldn't have more right and she
obviously has this organization with
this 1-800 number like it just wouldn't
be authentic if she didn't come out and
say it but like it's so much easier said
than done I was just like so impressed
and so I wasn't expecting her to say now
I did have some critiques of the entire
thing because I did think it was weird
that she stood in the audience when she
said it because the people in the
background like had to control their
reactions and there was a girl sitting
there like with her birthday sash and
Crown I'm like ah but she she got these
tickets for her birthday and it's just
like wasn't the show that she was
expecting oh my god she should have sat
in her regular chair and delivered the
announcement but that's just me it also
felt like she really didn't have a
teleprompter because she was like a
little over the place in a really
authentic way and usually like I mean if
I was coming out with something like
this I wouldn't need notes in the
teleprompter and [ __ ] you know but now
she was just out here being authentic as
hell I I totally agree I came I didn't
even realize that girl in her sash hold
on yeah the [ __ ] bow is very wily you
know you're not making a total of no
because I keep accidentally putting the
I pad on the string and you're also not
making attention I don't want it to
portray now I don't want to get my
microphone Cotta you know what a [ __ ]
bow like it not everyone could do it no
it's a lot of work being a [ __ ]
well I can't believe that's what it's
called and like this is the only time
you'll ever hear us say the word [ __ ]
on the show you know like it's a [ __ ]
bow but if it's accompanied by bow we
should sort of spin-off called the [ __ ]
bow show where we only have guests who
wear [ __ ] bows or capable of carrying
off a [ __ ] bow right like have the
Internet Middleton Brenda Lisa
Vanderpump no I think Melania Trump too
would be she would qualify she looks
great she looks great it
the first time I heard of a [ __ ] bow me
too and then because people were linking
it like on the website it was Gucci and
it was like a Gucci [ __ ] bow and so
everyone like now that I'm wearing a
[ __ ] bow I don't think oh if I'm if I'm
wearing the spoke people are gonna
associate me with a [ __ ] because like
it's too [ __ ] but when has aroma Simon
the shirt is so classy and so feminine
that it could literally only be called a
[ __ ] bow right what's more feminine
than a [ __ ] about anyways and I guess
is it that like when it when your [ __ ]
bow like is it called that because like
when your [ __ ] bowl a it's like it kind
of looks like a [ __ ] I don't think so
like the lace doesn't it doesn't yours
does it might kind of just I guess
that's how you know it's good we
shouldn't look into this the origins
history whatever back to Wendy Williams
it seems like she's in a very good
headspace and I'm very happy for her I'm
very happy for her I'm in a good
headspace to and I love getting answers
so far we have two answers two big
questions today messages and we're had
Wendy Willy this is called like the
morning solution and of course this
reminds me of Demi Lovato when she was
at a judge on I was gonna say she was
living in a sober living facility and
she was a judge on like one of that hi
he's getting paid 25 million dollars and
she was living in a bunk bed on a top
bunk she said it's crazy she too was in
a good headspace and she seems like
she's in a good headspace as well - yes
any because she's being right and I have
a good headspace you say I think I'm an
ingrate headspace actually I'm gonna go
ahead thanks to a lot of things
including headspace I started using
headspace a while ago I told you Olivia
one time made me use it and I fell
asleep but I was also drunk so I didn't
know if that was it that it worked and
I've been using it on tour a lot and I
made Margo do it and at first she was
like this is so weird we were listening
to the story and it was like all about
lavender okay basically headspace is
like a it's a meditation app and I use
it to go to sleep because I don't really
meditate but I do especially when I'm in
a hotel room have trouble falling asleep
so we were listening to this man with a
British voice talk all about the
lavender of the city of Provence and it
was so amazing and we fell asleep
literally like children it was wonderful
and so I'm a really big proponent of
headspace headspace is your guide to
health and happiness in fact just ten
days of headspace has been proven to
reduce stress and increase happiness it
will teach you the life-changing skills
of meditation and mindfulness in just a
few minutes a day
station is rooted in tradition but also
backed by scientific research and
headspace is hundreds of meditation
sessions on everything from stress to
sleep that's what I use it for start
your journey toward a healthier happier
life by subscribing to headspace sign up
now at head space.com slash toast to get
a free month trial sign up online at
head space.com slash toast for a free
month trial and start meditating today
that's wonderful yes
the lavender of Provan jaga it was so
funny like but he said it like you know
and that's really what made me fall
asleep and he was talking about it's
like you come over this hill and you see
all the purple lavender beautiful he was
really I listened to it like three times
in a row it was really beautiful we
should go there okay next story exciting
news music fans Woodstock 50th
anniversary lineup has been announced
Miley Cyrus jay-z chance the rapper to
lead the festival also John Mayer well
yeah there's a lot of things and we're
jay-z at Woodstock you know that's I
think that's the point so in August 1969
half a million plus music lovers road
trip to the wilds of upstate New York
for the three days of piece of music
Woodstock Music and Arts Fair from Jimi
Hendrix to Janis Joplin the rest is bona
fide rock and roll history why are you
laughing at a shop near Amish man
oh yeah 30 rock yeah where they don't
get the life rights to Janis Joplin so
they call it like Ginetta job lead enjoy
please yes John yes Janis joy I knew
that's why you're allowing come August
see the 18th a sprawling lineup of
contemporary music acts from what's left
of the Grateful Dead to Miley Cyrus and
chance the rapper will attempt to make
history all over again at the 1,000 acre
International Speedway in Watkins Glen
New York after months of online rumors
the official lineup for the 50th
anniversary concert was announced
Tuesday current acts such as Halsey
imagine dragons and Janelle Monae are
now set to share the stage with wet
veteran Woodstock artists Melanie Hot
Tuna and Country Joe McDonald it's all
part of what organizers hype as a chance
to unite the country again
so here's weird cuz like when you think
Woodstock when I saw it on John Mayer's
instrum and then you said Miley Cyrus
like okay those both make sense like
when you think like peace love flower
crowns bell-bottom jeans like you don't
think jay-z chants rapper you know it's
just a different genre no I think what
commonalities in Musgraves is so good
stuff right but I think 1969 work
Woodstock peace flowers bell-bottoms
that was the zeitgeist of the time and
so I don't think they're trying to
replicate peace love and flowers I think
there are honorable thing what is the
zeitgeist of 2019 and it is jay-z chance
the rapper total so here's some branding
is still like flowery bubble letters
because that's their sort of me on brand
like it's still woods I think they're
trying to incorporate both like they're
just try to make the Woodstock of our
time
yes exactly the fire festival was
supposed to be and the lineup there
really is something for everyone so
Friday the big headliners are the
killers so Ben where oh my god honestly
and then I was thinking like maybe we
should go no totally it's in upstate New
York we're gonna [ __ ] fly to
Coachella across the country we're not
gonna go in our home state right I'm
going to hesitate New York this weekend
me and Ben saw the killer's perform at
like a private concert at I'm sure was
in kind of all-star weekend it was
amazing and the lead singer is hot so
day one the killer is Miley Cyrus
Santana the Lumineers the racket owners
don't know them but I'm sure someone is
excited about that then the rest of the
day one lineup I don't know any of them
oh except run the jewels because I saw
them at UM panorama is it run the jewels
je wel sa bun that Ju you you LS it's
the first moment they should definitely
think about really totally day to dead
and company so i thats where i guess
john mayer's performing oh I thought it
was gonna perform like him chance the
rapper the Black Keys Sturgill Simpson
and then Oh Leon bridges is also that
day I know him Gary Clark jr. Edward
Sharpe and the Magnetic Zeros
I love them and that's all I know for
that day Oh India Arie oh love her love
her I've done I get down to the heart of
the matter
will gets we I love that song okay day
three jay-z imagine dragons Halsey Cage
the Elephant Brandi Carlile the country
artist that we should know and love yet
somehow we don't Janelle Monae young the
giant common then staples I'm just
reading the ones that we know but I'm
sure the guys know more Darrell by this
honestly I'm whelmed by the ideas Kacey
Musgraves she's
on it because I thought I was thinking
is there if you perform at a certain
festival is it like it exclusive like if
you're headlining a cello can you not do
anything else ariana grande I don't know
your [ __ ] bow is coming undone again oh
my god maybe I should just make it
tighter okay
it would tell me if my microphone is
being [ __ ] up okay and I'll sing well
everyone oh there we go yeah right get
everybody out of tight put that as a
big-ass [ __ ] bow if I've ever seen it
okay so will you be attending I mean
like I'll go if they give me four
tickets
oh that's true that's my mentality with
all music festivals I know they're
trying to reach at half a million mark
and it's like if they do I don't want to
go because that I have that crush your
obeah and that's just too many people in
one place and in this climate you just
don't really want to be there no totally
um but it's it's it's gonna be a no for
me dog it's gonna be a new for me but
like if someone tells me they're going
I'll be like cool for you I'm excite
seventy pics it's not like they're
telling me they're gonna fire festival
which like what people are saying it is
but like you guys know no I mean it's
not legit it could be a part of history
and if it turns out to be like a
historical thing that like in 50 years
is literally in textbooks I still won't
be mad that I didn't go no I would be
happy at home with my dogs but there are
people who read about 1969 Woodstock in
there like I was born in the wrong
generation I should have been there
gutted by it okay so like I hope you
guys all get the chance to go to this
one that's a great point and we're not
those people no we are not not at all
not at all okay like I feel like you
know people on their deathbed they're
like I should have been to more
festivals like more historical events
like I know in my death but I'll really
be like I should have spent more time
with my dog at home Billy also like I
actually spend a lot of time at concerts
and festivals because I'm at my happiest
at a concert festival it's there's the
treachery aspect so that changes things
and then and I feel like I go to a good
amount and I feel satisfied but yeah and
we have a good lineup coming this summer
of concerts we will make it to Celine
Dion before her final show in Vegas we
are going July 11th right for my
birthday to Florida Georgia line dan and
che at PNC Center
I think rascal pots are performing this
summer okay Zac Brown bands performing
this we're going to stagecoach
tentatively Coachella unfortunately
until a stagecoach
yeah actually we're probably more likely
going to Coachella than we are to
stagecoach so sad so sad but like we
become
work like we have to go anytime if me
now that I'm a revolve girl like I think
I have to go I think you did I think I
have to show those skinny [ __ ] like
what it's about right I'm just like I
think you love her about so much you
want the brand to be like you know more
inclusive in doing that are you I didn't
try to do that it can you don't go I
know it's like I expect more of them
like I was telling Ben last night so I
did an Instagram story last night
because I'm going to LA next week for I
have some shows tickets volleyball girls
on job calm and just like work stuff and
so I need like blouses and like dresses
it's hot in LA so I did a revolve order
and I realize like I'm like it's my
second revolve order this week and I
didn't agree I'm sorry I'm like it's so
fun I used to talk so much [ __ ] about
revolve but like I'm literally out here
being there I'm actually their number
one customer there's no way anyone
spends more money I'm revolving right
because even the girls who wear the most
room I'll get it for free so I'm like
it's just so funny how much I used to
talk and Ben's like you should really
work with them and I'm like you know
what it's so disappointing like I can't
because they're not inclusive and it's
like I'm out here just shelling like fur
there they have really out to you but
not like and they are not trying to
fishhook a path and also like you're big
influencer take you around the world you
know I'm not a 500 hour credit I need to
be seen I need to see the world and I
think we're evolved displace and it's
like they were like we're treating you
like a microwave once and I think that
was what was shown so yeah and it's like
they words with Ashley Graham once and
they like wanted everyone to Pat them on
the back like I'm sorry that doesn't
count
right like Ashton Graham is like a
supermodel congratulation it's not like
so you're lucky she would work with you
right where's escrow Lawrence where is
the justice nowhere to be found
so sabemos like you should work with
them I'm like it's not an option for me
because I'm bet so like Clem's unless
i'm whenever about this is watching now
yet so then I don't know if we've
infiltrated those off do we have because
I got a DM last night and I just like to
check my dams in the some girl was like
oh my god I work in headquarters I'm
coming your show and Irvine we love the
toast in the headquarters I'm like - are
you do yeah sure bring again where's my
check
where's my shot I'll have an 11:00
make-a-wish chest with boys just for the
boys just for the boys just for the boys
got it okay
next story exciting news that I didn't
realize was brewing Bethenny Frankel
makes a production deal with MGM TV and
Mark Burnett I saw she was thirsting out
of her Instagram stores with all of her
MGM merch
I don't follow her on Instagram and I
used the morning toast Twitter as my
personal Twitter to stalk and so I just
followed her cuz I was like she's always
making headlines with her tweet she's
always commenting on like but it's like
her theory is throw
[ __ ] against the wall and you'll go
viral well saying there's just too much
there when Paris Jackson responded to a
tweet that she didn't kill herself try
to kill herself
she responded to Bethenny Frankel's
tweet about it and then Bethenny to lead
in her tweet that was her first foray
into being like what the [ __ ] it's up
our talking about
so truly thrown I should hit the wall
power strikes if I respond to you right
yeah her Twitter its it's not my style
no her Instagram is wack like that's so
crazy because she's so yes focus she's
so smart and then you watch her in some
stories and you think she's losing her
mind but maybe that's just her creative
outlet and maybe it's like yeah she is
able to lose her mind on Instagram and
Twitter so that she can be a shark in
the toy room in the tank and in the tank
and jam television and Mark Burnett have
made a multi-year - Oh Bethenny Frankel
to generate unscripted TV projects that
she will produce some of which will be
star vehicles for her Burnett the MGM
worldwide television group chairman made
the deal directly with Frankel and her
attorneys at Grubman shire meal so us
and Sachs
Frankel has turned herself into an
unscripted brand since her getting her
start as a contestant on The Apprentice
Marc Martha Stewart in 2005 I didn't
know she was on that I think I knew she
was on the apprentice but I thought it
was after housewives like her first
stint on that Celebrity Apprentice she
would have been on but apparently so now
she was on a commoners apprentice hosted
by Martha Stewart Oh her cycle approach
honestly perfect for her natural yeah
job but not the real apprentice look at
the bill for intrinsic yes in 2005 and
then later joining the team on Shark
Tank both of which were produced by
Burnett she subsequently became founder
and CEO the lifestyle brand Skinnygirl
and stars in the Bravo series real
houses in New York City she has resumed
appearances as a shark on Shark Tank and
the ratings have responded we are
thrilled to have Bethenny join the MGM
television family and bring her unique
entertainment savvy that has been loved
by viewers since her appearance on The
Apprentice and shark tank said Burnett
well so this actually is a good foray
into a story we spoke about yesterday
that I would love to hear your opinion
on I think I know we were just talking
about housewives and TPG said that he
read somewhere Lisa Vanderpump was the
richest housewife and I'm like I don't
know if that's true and then we started
doing research and like pretty much
everyone said lizard Anna mom was the
richest housewife but then they were
also saying like LuAnn and Dorinda wrong
that was when I like I know for a fact
that they're 100% not um so I would love
to get your opinion on past or present
who you think the Bridget's housewife is
okay or was well I think Erika Jayne is
up there because she's the only one with
not one but two planes that's true so I
think they are the richest but then it's
Lisa Vanderpump eventually also those
planes could be the company planes
that's true but she then she wouldn't be
able to one take them on her tours with
her glam by the tube show it on TV
because that's like an abuse of
competent guarantee she wouldn't be so
brazen about it yeah um Lisa Vanderpump
though like she lives in a beautiful
house and she's always carrying you know
like rare colored pink Chanel bags races
her financials like I'm skeptical of and
I don't know why because she was like
this restaurant tour before Bravo but
now as far as I'm concerned her
restaurants include Villa Blanca sir
TomTom right
just-just-just she have clubs still in
London I don't know why she's never in
London I don't know and also like the
restaurant business
it is hard and yes it's not just like a
cash cow no not at all and most people
have multiple investors in their
restaurants like who put the money up
that's why Guillermo and Natalie and by
the way is the question rich a woman or
richest couple purchase family riches
yeah so again I think that's easier
honest and others who grows up there I
was thinking that too but then it's like
plastic surgery versus lawyer right
because I so cuz if it's if it's do
Burroughs do you include Lenny Hoxie and
what was his wife's name oh um Lisa Lisa
but then when I said it's like when I
think we're just has with Lea black
comes to mind the law law sorry I said
that we were lawyer Erin Brockovich JFK
like her and Erica Jane could be the
same level cameron Wescott plane yes
Cameron Westcott great call yeah I'm
just saying like there's definitely Lisa
Vanderpump is not I think Bethenny's up
there candy is definitely up there Lisa
Vanderpump is probably up there every
coach okay let's go richest by franchise
and then we'll complete that together
yeah okay so we have to tackle who's
Richard Lisa Vanderpump America Jane
honestly I think Erica Jane because the
because of the planes because of the
planes like I Lisa I don't mean I think
she flies commercial actually don't
think she goes anywhere she doesn't go
anywhere and she charters when she does
she did in previous seasons okay
also Kyle Richards might be up there too
because the agency but it's varying
it's new money whereas really Erika
Jayne is old money with the chapel in
her house right and like Tom is old so
he's been acquiring wealth for years
like Mauricio is still like young
compared I think I agree and I
definitely think that like tom has been
smart with his money for a very long
time
ain't drain Maloof so that's why I
brought up yesterday's when Maloof hoof
hats just taken off and the palms Vegas
yeah so she yeah look she's definitely
but then I'll get ready because she was
living in the same gated community as
Lisa Vanderpump at least appear to pump
downsized right but then also I feel
like I've heard some yeah the Maloof
money is her family's where's her
brothers really have the money it's not
so much her so I wouldn't include her oh
I wouldn't I don't know but I feel like
at one point there was something that
was questionable about like it's just
the question was it's not her wealth no
but her bra if it's her brother's it's
hers because like no it's like it's not
okay
like they owned the Sacramento Kings
that I think she has literally nothing
to do with it
and I'll get the team change the same
okay so let's go Beverly Hills I'm
putting the Erica Jane yeah but think
pastor present like not Carlton but like
was there anyone that we missed he was
like super wealthy how could they have
been like that wealthy and then not
still been on right yeah I'm gonna agree
on Erica Jane OC Heather Dubrow 1000%
past or present now Dallas come at Miami
or stepping Holmen I think Stephanie
Holman is very much on her way up and
like but I think the way that they talk
about the West got like they don't right
but is that more of a social thing
because actually no what no but when
they had him cleaning and in that house
oh yeah yeah yeah totally Cameron
Wescott Miami Lea black yeah New York
Bethenny yes right yes think of anyone
who's come and go no nothing okay I'm in
Atlanta candy yes I don't know Potomac
and but also their team no to matter in
this conversation right okay so should I
write those down okay yeah just cuz I'm
free to you March Madness no literal
riches housewives
okay we said candy Bethany who else we
say Lea Erica Cameron Heather Dubrow
Canty Bethany Lea black Erica Jade and
Heather Dubrow camera Wescott six
franchises do you forget someone
honestly out of this list I think
Cameron Wescott I think so too
that's crazy that's crazy cuz she gets
like the lease respect no by the way I
wouldn't be surprised if Cameron Wescott
has his shirt
once I was in percent I think she does
I've honestly seen like some her where
some things and I own and yeah and I
think that we have very similar style
but it's like we couldn't be more
different looking oh we forgot Jersey
well cuz they're all going into
foreclosure um no I would say the Gorgas
maybe but I wouldn't consider her to
beat out any of these other Oh Jennifer
no the house she lives in a nice height
her husband some Isaac surgeon what
makes more money what well I guess Joe
and Melissa have dual income yeah
no I definitely think Melissa has more
money than Jennifer hmm I think well we
know who doesn't have any money on that
job oh the reason why I thought that
well that could be Danielle now the
people of air totally the People
magazine list that came out with so
phoning me and tbg were laughing because
it had number two as Carol and teresa
giudice was on that list okay sad so we
knew it wasn't real but it's I don't
want to talk about it okay I think we we
did a nice job of sussing it out I think
so too
we made up we made a top ten mm-hmm and
I don't think we're so far off yeah okay
fifth and final story Disney closes
seventy one point three billion dollar
deal with Fox creating a global content
powerhouse Wall Street and other experts
have lauded the strategic benefits for
Disney but also highlighted the cost of
launching a streaming service later this
year which will be a drag on earnings
we've reported before that Disney is
working on launching a streaming
streaming service all Disney content
decom movies Disney shows etc are gonna
be on their movies me too honestly this
sounds fighting premium and I was
excited when I saw this news because not
only when we get all the Disney stepping
out that they're partnering with Fox
suggest got even more stuff right like
maybe they do they need a sort of like a
live stream show every morning with The
Fast Five story it's hosted by two
sisters who wear placebo shirts perhaps
like streaming muses always good news
for it I couldn't agree more because
it's just more content more ways of
getting our content to people more
accessibility
and I'm very much here for the streaming
services also I want to talk about trail
on Hulu did you watch it you know Ryan
no but I first watched your story you
should watch this only six episodes in
there 20 minutes okay I will I actually
thought I should why I know you're gonna
want to talk about it so I should watch
it and it's like if I just live my life
watching everything you're watching just
so you can talk about it then what my
first impression is that it's very
annoyingly giving me like girls vibe
it's like I don't know why it's like if
there's a someone who is the main
character who is like heavyset or just
not super skinny like every other person
with the TV show like why the discourse
on the show has to be about their weight
like why can't it just be the show
without people and the main character
just happens to not be skinny right or
like they have to be like sloppy no
she's not soft she's not no no I agree
with that it's always like if you're fat
like you don't care about anything else
it's [ __ ] no she looks mad cute all
the time right like rabbit Wilson and um
isn't it romantic yes I agree but no
it's like why does the show have to be
about the fact that the main character
is chubby it's just like why can't it be
a regular show that happens to star a
chubby person like right it's really
stupid annoying but I did enjoy the show
and it's relatability as a fellow chubby
person the Walt Disney Company has
closed its 71 point three billion dollar
acquisition of large parts of 21st
Century Fox explaining it's expanding
its global reach and content portfolio
ahead of the planned launch of its own
video streaming service with the mega
deal Disney led by Chairman CEO Bob Iger
is adding the Fox film and TV studio the
FX networks National Geographic Indian
TV giant star India giant star India and
Fox's 30 percent stake in streaming
service who look to its portfolio the
additional Hulu portion takes Disney
stake in the streamer to 60% with
Comcast owning 30% in 18 cheese warner
media 10% ohso missing since hulu yes
ray like a real testament to like and
he's always saying this and he sounds
crazy but there's a little bit like
three people who are in charge of like
the entire media who is it bob iger
oh wait does he say it's Bob I don't
know it's like he says it's like David
Geffen oh god yeah that's just not bode
well no but it's like they're it's true
right he's the one I don't know he's
shady with his boat but this is like a
true testament to how it's like okay so
it's like okay Fox and Disney whatever
but that also includes Hulu includes
ESPN ACLU's ABC like really there are
four people who control every single
media outlet it's crazy how do they
become one of them
and then it's like TMZ is owned by
Warner Brothers which is owned by what's
it a part of every one of them yeah
Warner Wawro yet Warner media you can t
write so it's crazy it's all the same
and how do we get in there and it's like
18 t is owned by DirecTV like it's all
the same [ __ ] Wow
it's crazy Wow Bethenny I sound like a
conspiracy theorist but it's turtle and
then didn't AT&T like require t-mobile
or something and if I can't become one
of those people like how do I date one
of them you know become friends with
their daughter yes so that you're in
that circle that's sphere of protection
yeah it's not even protection it's like
once you're in that sphere it's like
there's a show give it to this person
you know yes they just keep out shows
like Halloween Kim that's why it's not
even like anyone's dissing us it's like
they just don't were know us we're not
in the bubble right we're not on the
boat we're not on the bed we got to get
on that yacht but do we really want to
be on that yeah I don't know I don't
think so well I'm excited I'm looking
forward to having new options and
streaming services like I'm so over
Netflix and I've been into Hulu but
their actual app is so terrible and not
user-friendly and very difficult to
navigate that I find it difficult to
navigate it's so difficult it's like and
what if I don't want to watch the next
episode I want to watch indifferent
episode no but I just learned how you do
that how you see more all the episodes
how you hold down the center button like
when you're clicking on the show you
just hold down the button no what if
it's like how can who will come out with
this feature where it's like I'm
watching a show I gotta take a leak
I press pause how do I come back and
start playing just where I was ended off
they always take me back to another
episode like from a different season it
doesn't have a very strong memory no
just like it's like they forgot that I
watched two episodes past this I don't
know how they could forget nobody so you
were there so much it I watched you
watch me my hair feels so shiny today I
love it it looks shiny it looks very
healthy ah I'm just I'm so tired I've
really been cleaning like a lot this
week me too like just getting rid of
[ __ ] and because I'm moving I mean I
think you think you film the apartment I
think we found the apartment ow we have
to get the alarm well there was a big
problem in the apartment that I'm gonna
tell every I want to get this apartment
so I don't wanna jinx it I don't want to
[ __ ] out it okay do you have to tell at
some point after hopefully it goes
through this is the funniest story
that's ever happened but there's a video
and there's a video
it's so funny but yes I've been cleaning
out and you know I really have a problem
that I like far out too much Ben is like
always holding on to like this tissue I
cried on the fourth grade and I'm just
like [ __ ] off there do I where it's like
for me it's like this chain was passed
down from the Holocaust I'm like throw
it out like I [ __ ] threw out
everything it's so annoying I really and
then I go looking for stuff and I don't
have it I really need to start like
preserving my memories better and like
preserving all of the like cute pictures
I took in seventh grade on my digital
camera right well if I find it's the
video that is like on a weird VHS like I
gotta get that [ __ ] turned into a USB I
had the camera and it's like I can't get
rid of the cameras is the only way I
know how to look at the picture right
because I have a memory card throw it in
your legacy box send it out and it come
back and it comes back I guess see box
is one of those ideas that it's like how
did not we not come up with that and
haven't we been living with legacy box
like for the last 10 years it's
brilliant it's necessary and of course
it's been too much but since I've been
taking like a box of VHS is from an
apartment to apartment like an actual
like rom-com star in the 90s okay so
save your family film and photos from
degrading are being lost forever if
you're unable to play the recordings
back because they don't have a VCR
anymore or camcorders broken become the
family hero bring back lost memories to
watch and again again I'm sorry bring
back these memories to watch and see
again experience the joy of nostalgia of
reliving the glory days send your legacy
box filled with old home movies and
pictures they'll do the rest
professionally digitizing your moments
onto a thumb drive digital download or
DVD there's never been a better time to
digitally preserve your memories visit
legacy bots calm today to get started
plus for a limited time they're offering
our listeners an exclusive discount go
to legacy box.com slash toast to get 20%
off your first order
that's legacy box.com slash toast and
save 40% today get started preserving
your past
I like really need to start prioritizing
when it comes to memories because like
Ben has like Ben is a hoarder and I have
turned him into like in my eyes he's
still a hoarder but like for the real
world he's totally normal I just like
Canton was like clutter I totally agree
Zacks a hoarder and we've started let's
see box and I've sent some of my old
memory cards because I'm I actually am a
real hoarder but compared to Zack it's
like I don't think I'm a perfectionist
compared to Zack or a hoarder cuz he's
like worse at both things um so this has
been really great parts buddy and I
really when you're single self like
you've consider
yourself to be something and then you
meet someone you're like oh I'm not at
all like I'm Sherman bed was single like
he thought he was funny and then like he
met me he's not funny anymore right and
it's like you thought you were
particularly but then you met Zack and
it's like you're know I'm so easy all of
the apartments that we've looked at I'm
like seriously like it's not a big deal
but let's just pick one and we'll make
it our own like or we were looking at
two that were similar but different I
was like honestly I don't care I could
be happy and either he and he like to
him that makes me just like does is he
very easy right but like to me it's just
I don't care about the I mean I care
about the apartment but it's all pretty
much the same at a certain point and
then it's like once we're in there then
I get particular right but it's like
tell me where to go so I can be
particular there did you watch the house
of course I did you want to recover I
would love to I mean taking about watch
I'm inside know with Maren and teddy
know I did it was good it was so good
she was so cute she was so excited to be
there she was just being so respectful
like and she had so many great insights
because she's a real fan of Beverly
Hills she doesn't watch other franchises
and it made me really start thinking of
like when and why haven't we had a real
husbands of Nashville yet there is so
much there there's so much money I
always think about it when I'm watching
would be a very Cavallari Brittany Alton
yes you would yeah Brittany Hall Dean
like maybe some dan + Shay wives
depending on like Haley Anderson and
Marion is a but she's very busy yeah and
like when you think about it it would
become like a music show like it
couldn't be labeled Real Housewives
because if it's all like wives of
notable country stars you would have to
get some other people in there you know
ya know you can down like that Trisha
Yearwood you could get like a big wigs
wife yeah but you would have like a lot
I think it would be so interesting and
great if they became a music show would
be just so different from the other yeah
franchises I think it would be so good
we would need Tiffany from Dallas and
her Keith Urban look-alike of a husband
to move to Nashville and start the
franchise right cuz even need like not
everyone could be like a building some
people to just live in Nashville yeah
and a very Cavallari doesn't work out
like she would be good for it to she
would be great to live in Miami now no
they live in Nashville on a farm they
have like all these goats
nobody mm-hmm they're actually I watch
it every week now Sunday night Sonny
really have been coming back up and
Kardashians premieres next week um I've
been watching total Bella's it ends next
week I guess that's when Kardashian
premieres and I just really like it and
I never watch total divas know so I
think there's something about sisters
and just watching family members that is
just inherently
better TV and better morning shows yeah
than those without I couldn't agree more
you know like I just find the Bella
sisters so interesting and it's like
they are huge stars and it feels like
they have no management
no okay they are huge stars like they
are so recognizable to like real America
they're not like [ __ ] like
socialists like who is Alexa Cho
so my socialites like Alexa Chung is
arguably famous but like literally I bet
she has the most normal life and nobody
knows who she is but a society like
socialized have deemed her famous
where's like know the Niki and Bella
Twins whatever their names are are so
famous I'm like they get no respect from
like socialites
no it's but that's the kind of thing
that's the best that's a really money
but it's like they're always so spread
thin and I feel like they do have like
I'm sure their rep by veritable agencies
and they have managers but it's like the
way that they position themselves on the
show it's like they are flying by the
seat of their pants
right that's really it's like let's do a
pep rally for the Bella army which is
really cute I was minding of the
toasters and it was just cute and they
were crying and I just I love them and
then their stepdad is a WWE exec oh I
didn't realize that it's like butch is
immersed no I think he discovered them
and then I think their mom like mad I
don't know I need to I kind of need to
go back I need to learn more about the
history that'll be interesting okay
let's talk about Beverly Hills because
like a lot happens but nothing happened
and I just hate meal like that's my
takeaway from this episode and she was
in it so much and all she wants to do is
be a part of the show so every time she
gets camera time I'm like getting mad
that she gets what she wants right and I
was thinking about what Camille said and
hey she said it too and I have to say
what she said is a question that's done
a lot of people's minds so it's not
outrageous that she would ask you know
Camille and who's the other one um
Camille who are you trying to think of
and Denise are both like logically
questioning what what went down because
at the end of the day all of this could
have been avoided if - Reed had made
better decisions and they don't want
that to like be forgotten and I agree
with them and all the other ladies like
at this point in time except it's not
looking good for Teddy and Lisa
Vanderpump is kind of looking like the
unsung hero but all the ladies are just
so quick to jump on these seconds they
were like waiting for the moment where
everyone's getting ready and so like
Erica and Teddy are just like so thirsty
for for the reckoning which I'm Lorena
and Rinna that's what said Lisa you said
Eric and Teddy are so and yeah Riya
and I love that but at this point in
time it's like almost like they're
jumping the gun I agree and it's like
then it's like their intentions aren't
what are your intentions and trying to
bring down Lisa Vanderpump but I loved
how they brought it back to Camille and
the Taylor Armstrong I didn't even
realize I forgot oh my god what I can't
believe that when they look like you've
had your own experience with Vanderpump
you know sort of making you the fall guy
of it's like what could it possibly be
that Camille wasn't on for Telus when it
was let me talk about the abuse and
we're not going to talk about it but I
just said it so we're talking about it
and then she had a conversation with
Lisa where it's like you told me to say
that and says that I changed a bit it's
that then there was that conversation
with Munchausen's yes now with the dog
yeah there's a pattern here and it's the
magazines Brandi with Kyle there's a lot
there's a lot of news there was Brandi
Adrienne Lisa drama that's gotten our
'get cuz oh yeah it's the surrogate and
there's someone in your camp said this
yes so it's for a now cuz they're not
there but Brandi is I think actually the
biggest victim of it and you know who's
been there the whole time Kyle its Kyle
so Kyle knows and Kyle you're right they
have this arrangement where they the
show is popular because the both of them
have just had this friendship and this
this alliance and when that breaks down
it could have an impact on the show and
Kyle like the agency really got to where
it is a lot because of the show like him
with his hats coming on every episode
every season pushing the agency the
agency anniversary party the agency
holiday party we're gonna go to Mexico
open the agency Punta Mita like they
rely so much on the show for their
actual income that Kyle doesn't want to
rock the boat so she's staying on the
Savannah pumps good side for as long as
she can but I think later in the season
it becomes unavoidable right so right
now we're still in the point where Teddy
is looking questionable but to me I can
like I don't think there's anything a
lot of people are confused by what's
happening he said she said what's going
on Teddy lied I don't think Teddy lied
okay she did she left out
she lied by omission she she but she
branded herself in that entire week in
Baha Mar I am NOT a liar I do not lie
I'm in a truth-telling person but you
know what [ __ ] she left a big part of
the truth out but item and that's what's
making it look good for Lisa Vanderpump
yes but a lie by omission is not the
same thing as like I'm saying something
that's untrue I'm saying one thing doing
enough right you can't trust what comes
out of my mouth but it's also
what I'm not saying it's just as
important as what I am but when you made
it your business to tell the group and
brand yourself as the truth-telling
goddess that you are and then you leave
some big important detail out it's not
good but I think she left out that
detail because she didn't want to reach
to know how big it actually was that
there was planning going on between her
and Vanderpump like that Vanderpump is
that bad of a friend totally she's and
that's a and she's protecting herself
sure right she keeps saying she did it
to protect your eat which I do believe
there definitely was a level of
protection for jury but let's not lie
like you also didn't want everyone to
know you were in on like a manipulative
plan with Lisa Vanderpump you're
protecting yourself to that's fine right
honest but I think her intentions
weren't all bad and I totally see
everything that she's doing and makes a
lot of sense to me and I like I think as
a person who tries to be honest but also
like protect myself I think I would have
handled it in a very similar way and
when she's called out she just tells
everything she said okay then if I'm you
want to talk about how big it was and
that we were texting before here are all
the text messages and I totally believed
Teddy side of the story and that
Vanderpump did all of those things and
Vanderpump cannot answer the question
yes so and by the way
Kyle realized it last week at the lunch
after lunch I think yeah at Lisa's house
with Joey and Lisa because there's a
missing link so it's like she knew that
Teddy knew and she told Doreen that
Teddy knew but she can't answer how she
found out because she found out from
John says son John Blizzard right and
this whole argument that she doesn't
have communication with them like that
conversation I wish some one of the
producers would have shown victory know
the conversation she had with that
employee at her house where I was like
she was like holy in a purple it was
like a weird interrogation where she's
like they had a script that they
memorize but now also like photographer
photos like from past events from like
2016 I've been coming out of her with
John cezzah
right obviously she knows him it's not a
big deal and like even though Teddy
didn't tell the whole story still
nothing I was kind of out of her mouth
has been untrue lisa is all is a liar
and now in her interview she's being so
[ __ ] makuhita to Teddy and what she
does every season she's doing it with
Denise now it's like she's never mean to
the new girl Joyce Gerard
she's always nice to them so that she
can manipulate them and I think we all
thought that Teddy was that perfect
person for because even now I'm like it
will
work with Denise because Denise is
Denise Richards but honestly she's
pretty [ __ ] malleable yeah no no
totally lisa has always been nice to the
new girl for two reasons one to maybe
manipulate them and turn them into other
Brandi Glanville what she did with teddy
she's trying to joke Denise she did with
Joyce Gerard but she also does it
because every now and then like people
come for her and she always needs a
friend and it turned it it looks like at
the end of the season she has no friends
and in that Mexico magazine thing that
was the closest they ever got to take
him down Lisa Vanderpump she had not one
friend except for Easter argh yeah so
anything the wolves have return leading
the pack
exactly and she did because that bucking
Kyle turned around at the reunion but
they know what she always needs like a
little a Giggy like to be with her
yeah and that's what denise is gonna be
no because she's [ __ ] Bobby Fisher
and these are her pawns yeah being
friends with her is like being friends
with Bobby Fischer playing chess with
Bobby Fischer whatever
hence the pond'rous web scenes no I
started at a new geo Turin I feel like
Kourtney Kardashian but I wear organic
Gio Durant and have to say I think that
I was like living with Bo like my whole
life and you didn't know I think because
like I don't smell I don't smell good
I just don't smell which is great like I
slipped my armpits and after a long day
I used to use like like regular
drugstore deodorant putting on like
multiple times a day
okay the shower now [ __ ] smell I
started using KO party like coconut oils
you know Japanese Campari what did you
say and now that I used coke ari and
Jackie credit she used to go party first
I love coke ari it's my one of my
favorite beauty brands not for makeup
but just like for taking care of
yourself so the fact that you have found
love and cope are you it's just it's
warms my heart almost as much isn't
working my heart when they reached out
to us about partnering on the toast yes
so it's a it's coconut aluminum free
deodorant and honestly it's vegan I
don't know what that means but all i
care is that it works and I guess now
positive there's no chemicals in my body
which I really sound like Oreo
Kardashian but I'm like loving it but
the chemicals in deodorants are actually
wearable yeah and your armpit is like a
really sensitive area like for like your
glands or some [ __ ] so it's like you
don't want to be [ __ ] around there
yeah I've just been loving it and like I
find myself like sweating less and just
like not smelling and I just now I can't
help but think how long I was living
like as a smelly person it makes you
think do you find yourself needing to
snap a wrist and steal some cope re Co
parties coconut children goes on smooth
and doesn't leave behind a sticky white
residue along with their original
coconut coconut scent cope re offers a
fragrance free version of their
deodorant plus two new scents Beach and
gardenia they also offer their money
back guarantee so there's no reason to
but a try today go to cope re beauty.com
/ toast to make the safe switch today
and save five dollars off your first
order when you subscribe that's cope re
KO PA RI beauty.com / toast cope re
beauty.com / toast take of her me yes
it's a this is a sponsored post but I am
love Bing the deodorant I have like
three I throw it in my bag for tour in
my bathroom I love it I love it and also
I love everything else that Campari
makes and it's my favorite brand partner
I mean it's like when someone's snap
service and seals your Aparri now you
can replace it at Campari beautycon /
toast did you watch benefi brawls yes
wait are we done with um also they
didn't talk about like I feel like no
one's talking about Jenny's had that
dinner which dinner with her husband hi
I think she was high she was laughing on
marijuana oh yeah like not in a not
saying she's a drug yeah like but she
like she definitely had some they drink
of ganja her and her husband joined the
law or maybe they were drunk but she
wasn't acting drunk she was just like
being silly and laughing and I hit she
was I told on marijuana like not a big
deal it's just hilarious yeah totally
and they're getting married next week
which is crazy I know but it looks like
a bit of a [ __ ] show yeah but I'm sure
like then it'll be like it was beautiful
yeah totally
love um Camille's husband is hot yeah I
just can't explain it like I know
everyone's so happy for Camille I'm like
I am too I just like hate her anyway I
just can't believe she's like back in
the group she's on the trip she's on the
show and she's gonna go straight to 2011
Camille yeah and just like be like
learning a lesson you became the member
she was on the cover of People magazine
America's most hated housewife you know
you got there by listening to Lisa
Vanderpump and now you're back like in
her she thinks she's like I [ __ ] up
the last time I was here I got kicked
off the show because I wasn't in Lisa
Vanderpump's good graces and now
literally her dying wish is going to be
to be a mainstay on the show all she
wants to do that's why she did the ball
gag thing she's always trying to be like
funny and kitschy and like she's like
okay last time I didn't stick with Lisa
Vanderpump when I got kicked off so this
time I'm sticking with Lisa Vanderpump
but she chose the wrong Susan she's on
the wrong side of history and I don't
think she realized why people really
loved her and wanted her back is because
she had changed and she became just this
like nice sweet woman and they think
she's bad
she thinks she's back to be a million I
love how this awarenes calling her out
for being so wishy-washy it's like the
fact that not only she said that about
jury she said that to Lisa Rinna who is
the mouth right she wanted to be heard
of Beverly Hills she wants it to get
back as I was like how was a super
granny gonna handle this well she's Rima
she's gonna tell someone that was like
well that's my Camille told her right
I'm just thinking like we're gonna hang
out after this should we order lunch I'm
just like I want to be patient I have
some food at home good stuff
I think things say you could be happy
with like I'm trying to like be good but
I also enjoy my life okay I have some
grilled chicken okay I've some chicken
poppers Oh from where from I ordered
last night
okay sure okay fine I'll do that yeah um
okay so let's go oh cool and then a
purple rose to be talked about
oh no we did it because it was on Monday
Lala how to break down okay lalla did
not have a breakdown Lala I I mean I
know why Samuel and I apologize for her
but like and I know she had like
definitely a hard night on Twitter
Monday night cuz people were coming for
her but what people are not realizing is
she didn't just go off she heard Raquel
talking [ __ ] about her and her dad and
people on Twitter we heard people on
Twitter are being like you know just cuz
your dad passed away it's not an excuse
for you to misbehave and I agreed like
our dad has sway and we're very normal
lovely girls but if someone was out here
speaking on my father oh you bet your
ass I would be in that face with a
finger two months later totally of
course I would so then that just set her
off and then now she's coming for
everyone she's just on a rampage but
it's just such a bad timing cuz Thompson
involves like on this kick of being like
we all do crazy things that started none
of us get fired so now he's obviously on
a kick being like Lala should be fired I
mean that will not fly with me also I
think it's very different because when
James was being crazy for a while his
parents were getting divorced and so
Lisa gave him a lot of allowances so
first of all
Lala's dad has passed away so those
seeds even more allowances so if Lisa
were to give her to treat her harshly at
this time
that would be hypocritical it's not a la
la Lala I mean Lisa herself is also
grieving right and James isn't going
anything going through anything right
now someone else can I think that it's
like why you doing and I wanted to send
some things that really pissed me off
when they're all at Tom Tom and James
comes and they just invite him and he
freaks out two seconds before he was
telling Lisa I've changed I'm really in
a better place and it's like so she's
like I know you are you can DJed or
whatever then you can DJ brunch with
Billy then not too
he's out here screaming has to be taken
out to the garden saying your wife is
[ __ ] fatty and lisas watching and
doesn't do anything right and he still
gets to DJ brunch right it's [ __ ]
I'm not back hey Billy that ain't DJed
brunch was actually a really big deal
like he's back working at Sur when I
didn't realize that it was gonna be at
Sur and he's back at Sur yeah you know
it's it's just under a different like
rear end right it's interesting and I
just I love la la and I I don't know I
just I felt for her I thought that she
was right she was really being really
mean truck hell but Raquel was talking
[ __ ] about her like know about her so
when James comes in and says Sawalha
it says to Lisa I just want to tell you
what happened at brunch
she called like he'll see you empty like
you didn't start from the beginning
lying by omission and that's loud and
just wake up and decide to be set off
obviously she's talking to that girl who
was described as Lala's friend I just
don't think that it was this big of a
out of nowhere Lala's having a breakdown
as it seemed to me it seemed like
there's a very clear reason why she
acted because she's already in like a
fragile mental state and she's very
easily triggered she's going through
this tough time and you're gonna be out
of here talking [ __ ] about not only her
but her dad to her best friend are you
kidding me yeah I know
she already doesn't like you right so
here's all the other reasons why and by
the way and she did apologize to Raquel
for calling her a [ __ ]
right so there should technically be
clear there's no reason why Lala should
be talked I mean why Raquel should be
talking [ __ ] about Lala technically
they're in the end it's it's stale she
she started with her also then the other
argument is people are saying that
Lala's too full of herself like she's
acting like you know she's better than
everyone and she said that she's better
than everyone how do you think what do
you think about she kind of said that
but what she is so out of her I just
think what she should have said and she
should have clarified cuz Britney was
that girl created equal and I agree but
then some people behaved better than
other people and I think that Lala's
like she shouldn't have said I'm better
than them it's like but she doesn't this
is what she was trying to me hey there
is better you know she was like I don't
think I'm better than anyone else
necessarily like just just because of
nothing right but I just think like I
hold myself to higher standards and I
act like I would never like I've been
shooting for our counts dad died god
forbid a million times like she would
never go out here talking about her dad
they're different people want trash and
one's not right and it's definitely like
an Erica Jane situation where it's like
she has to commit many wrongs until I'll
admit that she
wrong but I just I didn't see this as
being so yeah look I'm deaf and my buddy
showed up and she looked incredible and
like she was wearing so much makeup out
of tears streamed down her face and it
was like that's what I want from my
reality TV member is like that sort of
dedication that sort of JLo dress and
like Jim I appreciate everything you
brought to brunch that day soon Simpson
physically and mentally and spiritually
sane love it love it okay and by the way
when the [ __ ] are they gonna go to
Mexico we've been talking about that
stuff I'm mentally I think they were
known in Mexico before time time open
but time times opening and they have
another Mexico threw a party before the
tomtom wedding like I one point I was
like I guess the trip fell through ya
know it's weird I hate that it's like if
we're talking about going to Mexico I
want to go at the end of the episode and
or the beginning of the next one
don't tease Mexico in front of me for
three weeks totally I mean Mexico thank
you guys so much for being here at the
morning toast the Millennial morning
show we go live Monday through Friday
10:30 a.m. Eastern Time on YouTube and
then we're also available it's a podcast
pretty much anywhere podcast can be
found Apple iTunes stitcher Spotify
public radio iearnt radio all that
[ __ ] I'm Claudia a shy girl throw
job your hostess with the absolute most
just please feel free to follow me on
instagram at girl with no job and
tickets are available to my dirty jeans
tour at girls no job com
this week I'm going to be in Phoenix
Brea California and Irvine California
and I would love to see all your bright
shiny faces that sounds fun I'm Jackie
ashtray Jackie oh problems please follow
me by the way scheduling update there
will be no show on Friday because both
of us are gone next week
I am it's a Jackie O takeover Claudia is
hitting the west coast doing her secret
project I'm gonna try to make it really
obvious what my secret project is I
don't care if people find out yeah yeah
and then also just like doing chosen
brand or vine and just like also going
on daily pop oh and speaking of you're
going on daily pop and Justin Sylvester
is hosting with me on Tuesday and it
will be later in the day because I will
just do anything to get him on the show
and accommodate his schedule this week
we have really premium co-host Nikolas
Nadeau together I only have one more day
to fill I'm voicing with Jared freed on
Monday because I've never met him and
this show is all about second chances
amen I'm Tuesday I'm hosting with Justin
the lady sitter I'm dead for [ __ ]
Steen's on Wednesday I'm hosting with
snitch because it's been a minute and I
want to hear from her we need us in a
show the show's situation and I feel
like when I see her she doesn't even
talk to me like I feel like I only get
to know her if I have to interview her
and she's last answer these questions
Thursday is open I'm filling it and then
Friday
I'm hosting with Ben who I have not
hosted with I think in six months and
I'm so excited cuz it's a waste of crowd
pavement and it's always the most viewed
episode if you have any recommendations
for Thursday like someone you know who
has influence who lives in the New York
area or will be in town let us know
we're trying to expand our horizons this
has become a little bit of an echo
chamber but the same for co-hosts and
we're trying to expand we are and we
just we want to serve a premium content
and we want to get to know more people
and and highlight new new voices in the
industry thank you guys so much for
being here follow Jackie and scram you
forgot to plug it oh no I did Jackie Oh
problems but I'll say it again also I'm
wearing the super cute outfit today so
it's like some premium content later bye
you